hey guys Stan here from civils Ai and in
this video I'm showing you our new
feature we've launched which is workflow
building and the concept here is on the
left I can select some knowledge base of
information this is input documents or
files that I want to use um in this
workflow so in this case I'm actually
going to be doing an example which I
think many people could understand which
is reviewing contracts for risks um and
in this case I can select my two
contracts that I want to use that I've
already uploaded into my project and
you'll see that both of those now being
input files you'll see here that
basically what we do is for these
different topics we do an rag search to
pull out all the relevant information
from this knowledge base we then have
these different tasks which are
performed so if you've used these
generative design tools before like
grasshopper you'll probably
instinctively know what we're trying to
do here but in this example I'm
basically uh giving one t which is
summarize this in plain English for the
project manager and then also uh score
out of 10 to these uh terms Provisions
so they follow the best practices so I'm
basically doing these tasks on all of
these different topics I can also add my
own so I can customize this all myself
like no two projects are the same and
you know teams work in different ways so
you can also add in here your own task
and all of this can be customized you
can even change these existing ones or
delete them um and then yeah you write
into an output file so you create an
output in this case it would be a Word
document and then you hit run so this
can take about 10 to 15 seconds to
process and then once it's processed so
this one took 14 seconds you can click
this view outputs and then when I click
the view outputs you'll see here on the
left all of these different topics and
then these tasks which are associated
with those uh in this case you've got
this output scoring it out of 10 roughly
uh so in nine in this case and then some
rationale providing its reasoning behind
why what what standard about it what
some areas for improvement and then
referencing different documents so here
it provides references to the sections
of these contracts so you can cross
check uh you can work your way through
these different tasks which have been
performed and reviewing all the outputs
and then basically you can download this
as an Excel or a Word document in this
case it's not really tables so probably
a Word document would be more useful if
you want an output um but yeah you can
also run this um to generate tables so
in this case I'm doing a risk assessment
searching things like buried utilities
from all of these specifications looking
at the interfaces site access
restrictions um so you can upload bids
and tenders and basically run all these
checks on it and in this case I'm
searching it's telling me what types of
buried utilities there are on the
project who owns them all these
interfaces on the project and how they
should be managed and then we have
templates for these different tasks you
don't have to create them all yourself
but you can if you want to um but we
have templates for different tasks like
we have some for for bidding right now
so for these types of risk assessments
like technical risk assessments contract
risk assessments we've got some for site
investigations which we've been doing
for quite a long time now with um
extracting bold data lab testing data
and all of these can be customized
yourself so you can run these however
you
like and that's it that's the latest
features